so my name is Edward Thompson today I
want to talk a little bit about your git
repository and keeping it healthy real
quick about myself I work at github I'm
a product manager I used to do version
control stuff but I don't anymore now I
do see ICD I'm working on a tool called
github actions which i think is awesome
and you should totally check out but I
do want to talk about version control
today in particular I want to tell you
how you can break your git repository
why would you ever want to do that well
in fact you probably don't I don't
that's where I keep all my stuff I think
that what you want to do is in fact not
do all these things but I do see these
come up all of the time so I want to
tell you things that you should not do
somebody on the internet once commented
on a youtube video of this talk that it
was totally theoretical and nobody would
ever do this that's a lie I've seen
people do all of these things please
please don't do them okay the first big
one is about your line endings how many
people think they've got their line in
and configuration really sorted out with
git really for real this time
I don't see a single head a one hand
congratulations for the rest of us what
is the problem
well there's this option in git called
core dot Auto crlf and get when you
install git for Windows at least asks
you what you want to do with that
setting and it gives you a default and
everybody absolutely thinks that they've
got it right do we in fact have it right
let's clone a git repository and find
out so I'm gonna clone a repository on
Windows I have core dot Auto crlf I have
this repository locally just in case
conference Wi-Fi is poor so I'm gonna
clone line and exact get into a folder
called line endings we're gonna take a
look at what is inside so if I run git
config core dot Auto crlf it'll tell me
what it's set to it's set to true this
is kind of the default default get for
Windows ask you what you
to do this is what it tells you to do
but you can choose your own adventure
your adventure is pain no matter which
one you choose
let's take a look I'm gonna change that
core dot Auto crlf false now I'm gonna
run get status remember I just cloned
this repository I have not touched it
all I've done is change a configuration
setting and now I've got a file that's
modified how often has this happened to
us where we clone a repository we don't
make any changes and all of a sudden
things are dirty oh it's terrible right
so what is the problem here well cordon
Auto see our left is a configuration
setting and configuration settings in
get our local to either your repository
or to your machine they're not shared
with everybody else so I can set Cortot
Auto see our left one way and I'm
putting files into the repository as if
that were actually set everywhere if you
change your court auto auto CRLs setting
to not be the same as mine now all of a
sudden we're making different promises
to get we're putting different content
into the repository
we're pulling different content out and
it's a total mess so please don't do it
instead put a get attributes in all of
your repositories it's very important
but that is the way that you can agree
with everybody using your repository on
the settings that you have okay that is
by far the most common thing I see
people do that is really unfortunate
with yet however there's more the next
thing I see a lot of is people changing
this option called core dot ignore case
almost all of the core settings are not
in fact settings their cache options
that get has used when you create a
repository when you clone a repository
it actually looks at your file system to
decide if it's an case-insensitive
system or a case sensitive file system
and it caches this so it doesn't have to
check every time it's a speed up for get
it's not to be changed why not let's
take a look I'm here on a Mac my Mac has
a case-insensitive file system if I go
into core dot ignore case I've got a
file called hello dot text now if I
change it to be hello text in all caps
and run get status nothing has changed
because fundamentally get knows that I
have a case insensitive file system and
poorly performed poorly behaving
programs will sometimes create a new
version of a file instead of like
updating the old one and it might screw
up the case this happens a lot so if you
were to change core dot ignore case see
right now it's true because I'm on a
case instance in a file system if I
change this this is a cache setting
again this is not something I should
really be touching now I run get status
oh now that file has changed and in fact
if I actually make changes to the file
then I'm in even worse position there we
go
let's just add some exclamation points
now I run get status and something is
both modified and untracked oh that
doesn't make any sense
I can't even add it like tab completion
doesn't seem to work right like nothing
is good here if I add it and commit it
then it's still modified how does that
even work and so I'm in a real painful
place and so what I want to do of course
whenever that happens in get I'm just
gonna clone the whole repository over
again right and that'll get me all out
of this mess definitely for sure
Oh clone doesn't even work anymore oh
this is a very bad bad place that I'm in
so don't don't do this please don't
change this cord out in your case
setting or any of the other core
settings like core dot precomposed
unicode whoa this one's a messy one and
if you're not familiar if you're not
familiar with Unicode normalization
allow me to blow your mind for a minute
how do you represent the letter e with a
diaeresis over it well there's a couple
of different ways depending on how you
like your Unicode you can either compose
it so that it's a single character that
character is a with diuresis or it's two
characters latin small letter e plus the
combining diuresis character basically
unicode says this and your operating
system says cool I'll make a glyph that
is e with two dots over it okay I don't
know why we need two different
mechanisms to to convey the same
information
but we've got them what's the problem
with that well you've got a pick one
when you create a file name and in
particular Mac OS will always pick one
for you if you try to create a file with
one particular form Mac OS says that's
cool I don't actually support that so
it'll change your file name on you
transparently good times what kind of
pain does that caused well now I'm in a
place right here I've got one file it's
called hello it's a very like metal
version of hello it's got metal umlauts
over it so if I run get status
everything is fine
if I run git config chord op pre-compose
unicode oh well
it's actually not set that's interesting
apparently that is in fact not cached so
if I change that to true no problem
change it to false and run git status
still no problem
that's fine let's edit this file
and see what happens that's actually
surprisingly that is actually exactly
what it should be saying in fact I think
I just had a demo failure and there's no
chance for me to recover it in a
10-minute talk so we're just gonna keep
going don't change it here's another one
fun one chord out protect NTFS and core
not protect HFS let's go back over to
Windows we're gonna go into this
directory core dot protect NTFS we're
gonna run git status oh I've got a
another strange problem which branch of
my own another demo failure I apologize
let's switch over here there we go
pretend there was no demo failure so I'm
in this right here we're gonna run git
status everything's fine I'm on the
master branch I'm going to unset core
dot protect NTFS and now my NTFS system
my my file system itself is no longer
quote unquote protected what does that
mean let's take a look I'm gonna check
out this nasty dangerous branch I have
here called NTFS I've just switched
branches and we're gonna get status ok
no problem everything is up-to-date
everything's clean I don't actually see
any changes what I have here is a file
called hello dot txt and then I have
this directory called git dot git is
where my repository lives this is an
important place this is where all of
your content actually lives whether it's
your objects your branch information
your configuration about git that's what
it means to be a distributed version
control system you've got all that
information right there in that
directory one of the important things
about git is that it doesn't let you
write into that directory if I want it
if I were to say run get add dot git
index that's a file in the dot git
directory it will tell me that it can't
do it right the dot git directory is a
place that only it can write to you are
not allowed to touch it people are not
allowed to check into it because you
could overwrite somebody's config and
all of a sudden start executing programs
you could overwrite some of these
objects and all of a sudden poison
their source code totally off-limits
until you turn off cord out protect NTFS
like we did now when I checked that out
if I run Durer I've got this file here
hello from inside your repository yes my
sneaky branch actually put that there
and it was able to do that because I
turned that protect flag off what is
inside my branch well it's got a file
called git tilde one hello from inside
your repository dot txt how many people
remember daus and 8.3 a couple of you
for those of you who don't remember dass
had 8.3 filenames when windows added
long file support they had to figure out
some weird compatibility for backpack
compatibility for dass and they did it
with tilde one at the end of a file name
so a folder called get maps to get tilde
one so I can add a directory called get
tilde one when I check it out on Windows
if I turn off cord out protect NTFS that
will map right into get so what I'm
saying is if I run dirt git I see my git
repository I run dirt get tilde one I
see the same thing so that's that that
compatibility still biting us in 2020
git has that flag cord out protect NTFS
to protect from that so you can't use
get tilde one unless you turn off that
flag so don't touch that flag pretty
please finally finally we have operating
reserved operating system reserved file
names different file systems cannot
represent all of the same file names on
Linux you can't have a file name with a
forward slash in it that's really the
only limitation and since get was built
by a guy who built Linux it also doesn't
really have any anything in the way of
limitations but Mac OS does Windows
especially does and that will come and
get you if you start using these things
so I can clone a repository reserved
names get
and what happens oh I can't even clone
this repository it tells me I can't even
check it out because I've got some weird
files in it but it tried and let's see
what it did
if I run git status oh I've got files
that are deleted I've got files that are
on tract right after a clone none of
this should be happening what's the
problem well I've got a file named aux
dot txt and aux is a reserved file name
on Windows kind of like com1 and lpt1 it
harkens back to again the old days of
das which are still biting us in 2020 so
you can't have a file name that starts
with aux if you do get the the operating
system will fail to write it get in this
case just totally gives up is this a
real life example yes
you cannot clone the Linux kernel onto a
Windows machine because there's an aux e
hiding in there somewhere
so please don't do that unless you just
really hate cross-platform compatibility
in which case go crazy linus torvalds
thanks for everything anyway in case you
forgot any of this please please number
one absolutely always remember set up a
git attributes file to take care of your
line endings do not rely upon Corte Auto
crlf it's not gonna get you all the way
other than Cortana see our left
don't touch the core configuration
settings they're not for you
they are caches that need to be
consistent they're there to protect you
and finally don't check in operating
system reserved filenames this was super
quick I thank you all so much if you did
not catch it all feel free you can find
out more information about the git
version control system how it works and
how you could hopefully not break it at
inside get calm thanks so much
you